Isn't this cute?
Well, maybe it's cute. So, call me when you're done. What do you mean by that? Is it to
improve your relationship with me?
[Music]
Nago You're a little big, I see. I see, I'm going to change my clothes. Yeah, that's right. But I'm a little horse.  I'm planning on doing
it, but it's true that she might be
cute.But Yuka-chan looks better than me, right?She's got a
56cm waist, but it's
a bit bulky, but Yuka-chan is thin, so it's
okay.Bye, you
stupid girl, you've got a complex.  It
's 5 cm, but it's about to be taken advantage of. It's about the size of a kid's cap. That's enough. It's
okay.
That's right, the person you're dealing with is an angel. Feel free to
use even the slightest natural characters. You're an
evil being.
Angel. It's time to go.  Kane
Yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
H